The joe rogan experience.
This is the whole theory on why,
why kids should not,
she'd see gentle porn because gentle,
you know what I mean?
Cause I grew up with like with like
finding a playboy magazine and then just
batting off to it until I found
another magazine that was,
you know,
kids today,
are you going straight to internet?
They're going to be fun
still.
Australian guys find the
magazines in the woods.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
In the Bush we find them.
Yeah.
Isn't that incredible?
And I always used to think
that some adults hidden it.
He probably looked back at it and I just,
some other kid hit it there and
the board and the simulation,
it was programmed now.
Yeah.
It's almost like he grew there.
You're supposed to find it.
I have to that environment.
I remember and I can show you young.
I was about seven years old,
seven and I found this picture.
My,
my mother was the only woman in the house.
I went through one of her magazines.
So we didn't have underwear catalog
sitting around like a Victoria secret
catalog or something like
that would have been good.
But I found this picture in
my moms' Women's magazine,
it was just this naked ticket and these
magazine never had a naked Titone it
before.
Right.
So I cut this picture,
this picture I masturbated to this
picture from about seven till ten one this
one tick.
Right.
And I found out at 10 cause
I was watching the news,
it was a picture of a
woman having a mammogram.
Whoa.
Yeah.
But I didn't know as a kid and I used
to think cause the other tick was in a
machine being squeezed down.
I was like,
I was like that must be some sex machine.
It's amazing.
That kept your interest for so long.
I still did the lingerie thing out
of the Sears catalog from my friends,
my mom's Sears catalog and I used to keep
it and I put it in mind like books and
like Heidi in a book and like pull it
out and look at it and masturbate and
shit.
I being the laundry,
you know like in the catalogs.
The old catalogs.
We used to have catalogs.
I remember there being,
I used to bike one of video and then when
I went to university and I was like 22
or something like that.
Um,
they used to keep on sending
me the catalogs because I
bought a couple of videos
years ago and I used to
keep them and they was just,
they were just like little pictures
of scenes from the movie though.
I tried it,
I never bought anything but
the catalogs once a month.
That was a big diet free and I was broke,
you know,
I was fucking happy I have that.
I always used to keep my room mate one
catalog behind so he would get the new
months one after I got my new money.
It's funny that what you would want then
to see naked girls to look at it and
girls that people would deny that of you.
They say you're not ready for that yet.
I mean that's what it's all about.
It's about protecting kids.
But clearly you have these sexual crazy
urges and everyone's just in denial
about it.
No pure,
only 16 you can't buy a playboy.
Like you can't even buy a playboy when
you're 16 you can't even just let me see
a little tinny.
I don't even need to see a vagina.
Can I just see a lag?
I put it in movie.
He's when you're 16 weeks,
so I've got a command Britain now where
you are on page three the newspapers,
there's a topless girl.
Yeah.
Normal.
No ways.
Right?
That's good.
16 year olds can't go to
the movies that show tits.
Tits is not,
you can't,
talking about Porky's as a bit of technet
is important as our wouldn't Porky's
beat.
I think back then it was,
well,
we in to strike letter m
which is 16 and a half.
Yeah,
maybe that is our,
yeah,
sure.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
but we have our as well,
but mature was 16 Oz.
18 there's a 17 I think is
our and NC 17 is for you.
No matter what.
You can't even go with that
adult unless you're 17 my,
my father's so deprived of being able to
see tits and because my mom such a big
hefty woman and,
and he just,
he just,
but he's still like a Horny,
you sort of bloke.
My Dad,
right?
So when we were kids,
if me and my two brothers
were sitting watching,
let's say the movie labyrinth,
we all watching like a very innocent
puppet related film all at once during the
famine,
he'd be alone in the house.
We'd all go,
ah,
look at those tits,
Ma.
Within seconds,
my dad would just casually walk out and
sit and watch the rest of the film with
John and go,
what are you,
what are you going to watching?
Like
go all the way through
the film and then you go,
oh,
I might want you to be
getting in that film.
I missed what happened in the beginning.
Trolled him.
You'd trow,
oh,
that's hilarious.
And you,
you let him sit through the whole movie.
I said,
we don't go off and play.
And then you'd have to sit through
the first 30 minutes again.
Like,
oh,
that's fucking funny.
Just in the hope,
because it was gonna come.
It's going to happen.
You guys should've filmed that.
That would make a whole
area short film this,
explain it and have
them near the time code.
We could still search and
he could still do it now.
You should do this.
I could see it.
I get why it's filmed.
The light of the TV is what's on him.
Right.
Little time code in the bottom.
Show him 10 years later,
20 minutes later,
30 minutes later.
Look at us.
What
areas they could be hilarious
if you explain it to the camera.
He found some porn magazines
or they were retained in this,
but he found some porn magazines under,
my mother found a porn magazines under
my bed and she put them in the bean cause
that's like,
oh no,
you know you put them in the Bin and
then she didn't say anything to me.
She's letting me off Scot free on it.
She didn't like get angry or anything,
so I felt like I got away with it.
But my porn draw was empty.
Right.
And I worked in news agency,
so I used to collect them from the
bins out the back of the news agency.
So I had piles and piles of them.
I was a paper boy.
All right.
So I,
uh,
I was in my dad's work bench
and I was hammering a nail down.
I look onto the bench and
there's all my porn magazines.
They're all dogeared and they're like
lettuce leaf on them and stuff because
what happened was my dad's got a tight,
he's got to take the bean
to the end of the driveway.
On a Wednesday he opened the garbage bin,
solar porn,
he recovered at all.
I took it off to,
we shared very good mass device.
So I collected it all back off and I
took it back to my drawer just cause,
you know,
circle of life,
right.
And uh,
my dad comes home in the living room,
he comes out and goes,
Jim,
you guys were you in my garage?
And I said,
all right.
And I got Yay.
And you guys,
you know,
have those magazines and I wait,
neither.
You and I was about 13.
It says,
you said neither you and he went,
ah,
can I have four?
Right.
There was an actual moment where I
start with my dad and I had a debate,
but I was 13 over,
all right,
you can have a hustler,
a paint house,
a playboy.
You know today's your phone.
Not My phone is your phone,
right?
You can't leave your phone by the thing.
How many times do we have to tell you?
You get that crazy zap,
Zap,
zap my hair planes crash,
man.
I know you can't leave that shit
right by the MP three player.
While you're getting texts,
would you rather kiss Nancy
Reagan on the lips or the Ted?
You ready to record recording?
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?